die perfekte beziehung sollte man seinen
freund oder seiner freundin was schenken
also ich finde so erstmal klar was mich
aber voll aufregt ist ja bald dienstag
ich meine wer hat es erfunden schenkt
eurer freundin euren freunden was zu
weihnachten zum geburtstag oder also
keine ahnung zeigt den 365 tage im jahr
wie wichtig diese person ist und nicht
zu valentinstag ich meine wahl ist dass
das ist meiner meinung nach der größte
scheiß erfunden wurde ohne witz
gestellten gehören zu einer beziehungen
dazu wie ungefähr der grabstein zum tod
super guter vergleich sind supergut es
ist schon irgendwie integriert es ist
schon irgendwie
es gehört einfach zu einer beziehung
dazu dass ein junge zwischen durch
irgendwelche kleinigkeiten schenk da es
irgendwie eine blume oder was weiß ich
geschenke müssen ja nicht immer
materiell sein es kann ja auch meinem
herzen sein zeigt bin einfach liebe oder
so was meint ihr doch was schönes eltern
konnten auch immer früher geschenke die
selber gemalt waren gut also macht es
doch auch in einer beziehung oder man
sieht dann wenn du so aus als ob er kein
geld manager fällt oder da geht das geld
denn da ist das geld verschwunden
ja eine ganz schwierige frage ist
natürlich wie sieht das du mit anderen
mädchen aus bzw andere mädchen auf
instagram folgen oder so wo ich mir
denke hey klar kannst und auch anderen
mädchen auf inseln folgen wenn einer
beziehung bist du kannst auch weiterhin
andere michael hübsch oder geil finden
du kannst auch weiterhin bilder von
anderen mädchen leiten kann man sollte
aufpassen was für bilder eventuell aber
warum sollte man das plötzlich nicht
mehr dürfen ich meinen wir sind alles
nur menschlich bin junge da draußen und
auch viele mädchen die man die videos
gucken auch von ihrem freund habt ihr
dürft ihr noch andere jungs die zum
beispiel mich oder nicht meine nummer
ist natürlich in der video beschreibung
der beziehung was man unbedingt beachten
muss erstens ihr müsst ihr so abonniert
hat wenn ihr ihn so eine seite folgt
geile checks die besser aussehen als
seine freundin and folgt den wirklich
dass es kein gutes karma was in der
beziehung dann aufkommt oder was
natürlich auch sehr gut ist andere
können sehen was du lac aufpasst mehr
angesagt hier guck wirklich genau ob und
was du läufst jeder like ist wichtig
manche träumen nicht jeder will ich
damit sagen nicht jeder ist ein stalker
aber sehr viele gucken nach was du
soulor
deswegen fast lieber auf was du so
leicht fallen gehen mit seiner freunde
ist finde ich so eine sache so klar es
ist manchmal cool so sie zu fragen
willst du mitkommen aber irgendwie so
immer als auch scheiße oder also auf der
einen seite keinen fall gehen mit
freunden natürlich super cool sein so
auf der anderen seite verstehe ich aber
auch nicht diese leute die sagen ja
meine beziehung ist hat man in der disco
nichts zu suchen ich meine disco wurde
nicht erfunden und jeden abend fünf
verschiedene [ __ ] sondern um musik zu
ein bisschen spaß zu haben da verstehe
ich überhaupt nicht klar kann man alle
in die disco gehen wenn man befreundet
hat oder mich mein dort irgendwann hört
ja mit der freude feiern es gibt
verschiedene arten von jungs und es gibt
auch verschiedene arten von jungs die
gerne mit ihren freundinnen feiern es
ist mir sehr gut auf einer feier einfach
seine freundin dabei zu haben mit denen
anzutreten weil manchmal ist man dann
irgendwie noch besser vereint aber da
gibt es natürlich auch solche tage wo du
einfach mit dem gros zusammenhängen
möchtest und kein weib dabei war soll
nicht eins es geht meine grenzen die man
als die gibt es einfach ist darf nicht
jedes mal gefeiert werden mit der
freundin andere bei mir jetzt weibliche
freundin haben so klar das kennt ihr
diese leute die sagen verschiedene
geschlechter dürfen nicht untereinander
befreundet sein die sind füreinander
geschaffen uhr umzug oder was mir fällt
dazu auch gar kein weiterer
argumentationskette eigentlich meinen
klar ich hab weibliche freunde und ich
werde immer bei vier freunde haben klar
ich weiß ich kann man kann doch mit
jeder person befreundet sein egal ob sie
nun oder nicht ihr müsst manchmal
wirklich nachdenken welche freunde
verhalte ich noch eine eifersüchtige
freundin kann eine freundschaft wirklich
sehr einfach zerstören den konsum
vermitteln sprechen so mach dich nicht
so an ich will nicht dass du viel damit
immer oder noch viel besser treffen ich
bitte nicht mit denen also wenn ihr
diesen punkt habe dass seine freundin
die ihr vorstand mit wem du dich zu
treffen hast dann ist schon irgendwo was
bald ja das will ich jetzt auch nicht so
sagen man sollte sich nicht jeden tag
mit einer anderen freunden treffen oder
wochenende mit der einer freundin
da will ich gar nicht sagen dass das
jetzt richtig wäre also von daher müsst
einfach irgendwo ein level film wo ihr
drauf an spiel so wenige freunde da
plötzlich da und so weiter so fort es
ist alles zu sammeln was ich euch noch
sagen kann scheiß drauf was die
gesellschaft euch vorschreibt macht das
für robocop serie verletzte leider nicht
und dann ist gut man ihr könnt tun und
lassen was ihr wollt zwei wagen dazu
und ja ansonsten hab ich das video hat
euch gefallen wenn ihr mehr in diese
richtung von diesem neuen format sehen
wollte lassen auf jeden fall jetzt mal
doch nach oben da tipps wie du also der
zweite teil von dem brand mit dem video
voice und in der video verlinkt schaute
auf jeden fall mal vorbei ansonsten ist
sehr umstritten weil sein geblendet wir
sehen uns am nächsten dienstag wird ein
schöner relativ